make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and i want to cover the current
run of the eternals we're only about
three issues in and it's a monthly
series so it's one comic every month
um so it'll probably be kind of a slow
going thing but the story is really cool
so far and i'm curious to see how you
guys would respond to it uh but one of
the things this does is it basically
opens up
with icarus essentially being revived
now to give you guys a little bit of
context here and this is exceedingly
important
we go more in-depth into this in our
eternals explained video so make sure
you check that out it'll be linked down
in the description but the whole point
behind this is that the eternals
originally believed
that their modus operandi right the
reason why they existed in the first
place
is because the celestials had appeared
on earth and they had basically modified
the genes of early man
and part of that modification resulted
in the eternals but the eternals existed
to basically kind of safeguard humanity
to guide humanity because that was part
of the celestial experiment and the idea
was that the genes of a portion of early
man had been modified so that in the
future they would develop powers and so
the eternals essentially protected
humanity from the deviants and so that's
why the eternals of the deviants were
always at war
the the thing that kind of leads into
this and the story that really kind of
gives us the explanation for why icarus
is being revived in the first place came
in all new all different avengers and
this was basically the revelation of the
dark celestials now that story built on
a previous story but the two kind of go
hand in hand and the the complete kind
of event that was given to us here was
that the reality of the eternal's
existence was to basically be like a lid
on a petri dish right
the truth about the celestial experiment
was that every planet they visit and
every planet they experiment on
will be destroyed right it's only a
matter of time before it is and the way
this works is you have the celestials
and then you have the horde and the
celestials kind of represent absolute
good so to speak and that's a loose term
that i use
but it's the closest we get if we
compare it to like morality in
comparison to what jack kirby originally
wanted to do with the eternals in the
old stories he did back in 1976
and then the horde kind of represent
absolute evil and the energies of both
of these groups are fed on by
being called the fulcrum so the way this
works is that when an experiment is
conducted on a planet by the celestials
a portion of those genes are modified so
that at a future point in time they'll
develop powers hence the reason you get
mutants in marvel comics
after some predated amount of time which
is described as 19 cycles i don't know
how that how that compares to real world
time
then what happens is the celestials go
back and then they basically harvest the
planet and if the energy of that planet
matches the energy signal
of the deviants then all the energy of
that planet goes to the horde which is
just kind of like an evil group that
exists out there
if the energy of that planet matches the
energy of the eternals then it goes to
the celestials and so as a way to kind
of maintain this balance between the
celestials and the horde quite literally
they're vying for energy based on a
particular planet what this meant is the
eternals learn the truth of their
existence so they were basically just
kind of security guards just keeping
humanity safe so it could be harvested
at a future point in time and even the
eternals themselves would be harvested
at a future point in time this basically
led to the eternals going insane and
then killing each other right they just
went nuts like
and some of them committed suicide most
of them just took each other out right
it was just like this insane
level of of existential crises that they
just couldn't handle and so the result
is it was marvel's way of just kind of
killing off all the eternals just sort
of striking them from the entirety of
the marvel landscape
uh and presumably doing so so they could
reboot them at a future point in time
right this was done
less than a decade ago and so i have to
believe that marvel was kind of gearing
up for the possibility of them doing an
eternals film
and just kind of setting the stage so
they could bring them back adequately
and that's what happens here and so the
result of this is you end up having
icarus who is essentially
kind of resurrected in what's called the
exclusion zone now the exclusion zone
serves a couple different purposes in
the eternals mythos
the first purpose is that when an
eternal dies if a resurrection is going
to happen
they resurrect them there the second
thing is that it serves as a prison so
if there is an eternal that defects from
the cause right if the eternals are
there to protect humanity and an eternal
comes along and says no we should
enslave humanity and then like goes on a
campaign to kill as many humans as they
can
they'll be locked away in the exclusion
and they'll be left there until such a
time as they either repent and
understand the error of their ways
and go forward as a proper celestial or
they'll stay there until the end of all
things right presumably until like the
world's destroyed or the celestials call
the eternals or whatever the case
happens to be
in this instance it's where icarus is
being resurrected now when he comes back
he actually ends up coming across
xeros and zoros is now currently the
prime eternal and one of the things they
talk about here is the idea of the one
mind
the one mind is basically the unimined
and kind of a a quick synopsis or a
quick explanation again based on what we
talked about
in our eternals explained video the
unimine is basically when the eternals
come together and quite literally
combine their minds and energy to create
a singular gestalt energy source
that basically makes decisions it can
also be used as a weapon right like if a
threat is dire enough the unimine can be
formed which is like the collective
energy of all the eternals and is quite
powerful in its own right
and so the decision was more or less
made because icarus is the last person
to return
icarus was previously the prime eternal
or the leader of the eternals
because he was the last to die he's the
last to be resurrected and that in that
time frame
the unimined was formed and xeros was
chosen to be the leader now in my mind
it always should have been zoros who was
the prime eternal and the reason why is
because he's one of the oldest eternals
in existence and in fact
i think him outside of alars he is the
oldest one he's the oldest son
of kronos but in effect he's a second
generation eternal more or less and the
reason why i say that matters is because
given the history of the eternals if you
guys check out my video on the eternals
explain that we basically talked about
this idea that when they were first
created by the celestials that what you
had here was kronos and uranus and
uranus
incited conflict he incited a civil war
against the eternals and then in turn
he incited a civil war among the
eternals which of course led to uranus
being defeated ultimately he was cast
off of earth and then eventually settled
on saturn's moon titan and then of
course there was a great big huge civil
war among those individuals
but kronos had two sons on earth the
first was zoros and the second was alars
alars as you guys know
eventually went to uh titan following
the deaths of uranus and his forces he
married sui-san they had a couple kids
one was eros also known as star fox the
other was dion also known as thanos i
never agreed with marvel changing the
name of thanos to dion but the important
thing here is that zoros remained on
earth
and so as essentially the oldest eternal
he always should have been the one to
lead i think in the end marvel basically
chose icarus just because of his
popularity among comic book readers but
it makes sense that it would be xeros
here and so it's one of those things
that doesn't necessarily
sit well with icarus um but i think
again it's a good call because icarus is
kind of
headstrong right he's very brusque he's
not much in the way
of a leadership style in terms of his
personality but at the end of the day
the choice was made
and he simply has to follow it and
that's one of the things that's
established here when the unimine makes
a choice the choice is made and that's
it there's no arguing against that
if if icarus were to go to zoros and say
no you do not need to be the leader of
the eternals i should be the leader of
the eternals he'd be cast away to the
exclusion zone
because in effect he's committing heresy
against the prime eternal and so again
it's just one of those things that he
just kind of has to deal with
now in the midst of that of course as
he's kind of traversing around and
figuring out what's going on here he
ends up coming across
sprite this is one of the funny things
that marvel comics did so the idea
behind this
is that sprite was originally a guy
marvel switched him up to a girl
i'm sure there'll be comic book fans who
are going to be mad about it i don't
really know why it's not like they could
give me the history of sprite without
looking up a wikipedia article in the
first place so they're basically mad
about something they don't really know
anything about but at the end of the day
i think it's kind of a funny little
thing right it's kind of a cool little
maneuver and there's actually a reason
why this happens
but the problem with sprite is sprite is
basically the eternal's version of loki
that's really what she is sprite causes
problems right sprite is just kind of a
prankster a trickster there was one
point where sprite actually
wiped the minds of all the eternals so
it was kind of nuts in terms of how all
that happened but that's kind of a cat
and mouse game that sprite always plays
with icarus and the other eternals which
is pulling pranks they track down sprite
sprite maybe gets a little bit of a
stern talking to you or a slap on the
wrist and it kind of goes on right it's
just sort of par for the course
when it comes to the character the
biggest issue with this is that as
icarus is chasing down sprite and kind
of playing this little little cat and
mouse game
sprite teleports to new york city and
when sprite gets there suddenly
everything is brand new now a lot of
this is because of the fact that sprite
has more or less been backed up from a
previous memory that that sprite had the
result of this is that
while sprite has experienced all this
before the idea of humanity in its
current form
is known to sprite sprite doesn't
remember right just because of the fact
that that again the memories that she
has here
are from before she had essentially
encountered any of the regular
earthlings in their current form
and so by all standards of measurement
it's a whole new experience and it's
awesome
because sprite's like look at the things
that they've achieved this is awesome
you know this is cool but it's also kind
of icarus catching up sprite on a little
bit of her history and seeing like you
have kind of caused problems of the past
and like you literally tried to kill us
all now in the midst of this
they're met by the arrival of iron man
and this is a cool little moment here
for a couple different reasons one
iron man and icarus have met so many
times in mobile comics this is not a new
thing right it's not a brand new concept
but it's kind of cool because like iron
man
asks like are you gonna freak out again
and again this ties into the deaths of
the eternals and the reason for that is
because
with everything going on regarding the
dark celestials that iron man and dr
strange had actually sought out the
eternals because they regularly commute
with the celestials if there's anyone on
earth who's an authority on the
celestials it is the eternals right they
they know each other
intimately and so the results of this is
that the last time iron man saw icarus
he was freaking out and like all the
eternals were killing each other and so
that's why it's kind of like are you
gonna
kill each other again you know is that
is that what's gonna happen you know i
was like no
no we're good man and so it's kind of a
funny little thing and so ultimately
iron man is like okay cool
by the way man give my number to cersei
you know because like she's kind of hot
and it's
it's weird right like it's a little
weird like iron man's trying to get with
a woman who's something like like 10 000
years old or something on those lines
probably older than that maybe closer to
like 20 000. we don't get a definitive
date on how old cersei is but like she's
old now in the midst of all this
essentially excess deviation is detected
by icarus and the result is he
and sprite have to respond to it now
what's excess deviation so the eternals
are constantly at war with the deviants
they're always at war
and it's almost kind of like a internal
alarm system to a degree in the sense
that if deviants are in proximity
eternals will pick up on it and the
eternals will go and attack deviants but
only under the condition that deviants
are
essentially doing what they're not
supposed to be doing in this instance a
deviant captured a human being under
normal circumstances the kind of rule
the unofficial rule between the eternals
of the deviants is you stay away we stay
away right so you guys stay down there
in the underground and you do your thing
and we'll stay up here but as soon as
you guys step out of line boom we're
there right and we'll put you guys right
back in check again we'll kill whoever
we have to
in the process and it's almost kind of a
sport right it's almost one of these
things
where it's just kind of like okay like
you know this this kind of narrative
that's given is like for icarus it would
be a fight right for sprite it would be
a game but for them but because of
something that they've always done right
like when when deviants deviate
eternal's correct
it's one of these things where it's like
we lust for the chance to fight deviants
right it's just
what they do so like that's one of the
reasons why you kind of noticed that the
trickster nature of of sprite
suddenly vanishes and it's like okay now
it's time to kill some deviants
like it's a cool thing right because
ultimately they end up taking this
deviant out and they save the human
being and then they take him back to the
surface
and of course they end up going back to
olympia now olympia is the capital city
and the reason why it's called that
because you would probably immediately
associate this with
the the greek god home of olympus this
actually happened in the very early days
so the eternals following their creation
began to come to the realization
that gods like zeus and hera athena
apollo aphrodite that they were
basically meddling in the affairs of
humanity and while the job of the
eternals was to essentially guide and
protect humanity with them realizing
what was going on there wasn't enough
going on there for them to like get
involved in the sense that like the
greek gods weren't just
indiscriminately killing humans they
weren't really a credible threat to
humanity it was really more
than just kind of getting involved in
humanity right so like zeus running
around and banging girls right and like
aphrodite banging dudes right that was
essentially it right and so they took a
passing curiosity
eventually a kind of alliance formed
between the two groups
if for no other reason than the fact
that one they both operated on earth and
two the eternals wanted to keep a closer
eye
on the greek gods eventually they became
more allies than enemies or anything
like that
but it's one of these kind of
interesting instances where the eternals
sort of allied themselves
more with one group than another because
you never really saw the eternal
spending a lot of time on asgard and
hanging out with like odin
and loki and thor and those kind of guys
largely because asgard's in his own
pocket dimension outside of earth so you
literally have to leave
earth and travel to a different
dimension to get to it uh but
nonetheless it's one of these these kind
of interesting situations
because once they arrive there because
sprite is effectively meeting zoros for
the very first time
or at least the first time since uh
sprite's return it's kind of one of
those things of hey
like make sure you pay proper respect
when you get to the prime eternal the
problem with this is they come across
fastos
fastos of course being somebody who's
not really a pacifist but he's not
really huge on war but is really more
just like the technology guy the
eternals who essentially reveals that
xeros has been killed right somebody
killed zoros they effectively teleport
it in and teleport it out but the the
crazy thing about this is despite
eternals being nearly invulnerable and
being exceedingly difficult to kill
somebody brushed the head of of xerox
with their bare hands and that's why
it's like okay
who in the hell did this right like who
in the world could have done this now at
this point you get to druid druid
is just kind of a dick and at one point
was an enemy of the eternals like their
main foe
but it's one of these things where
initially the question is like could it
have been sprite but immediately people
are just kind of like
no like one sprite's not strong enough
to do that and two while sprite causes
problems i mean sprite wouldn't
kill the prime eternal would she
[Laughter]
but drury actually pinpoints directly to
icarus and it's like icarus was the
previous prime eternal
and icarus last i saw was none too happy
about the fact that the unimine
determined that xerox would be the new
prime eternal
this guy's got motive he's got strength
he's got the ability to pull it off
icarus at that point just headbutts the
hell out of druid and it's just like
that's ridiculous and then effectively
just leaves now at this point it's on
the hunt for the person who did this
right and so what they end up doing
is basically teleporting to titanos the
fallen capital of the eternals now
titanos was the original capital of the
eternals that's why it's considered
fallen it's more or less been an
abandoned place
but once they get there there's this
kind of hunting around there's this
almost kind of
excess deviation that's that's really
felt by icarus but not quite but at the
end of the day
the question is okay this energy source
that we've traced to this location
who has an effect like destroyed
whatever eternals were left here
there has to be something going on and
ultimately you end up having this kind
of vision
that's given to uh icarus of some kid
named toby robson who ultimately ends up
dying at 13 years old
and so it's kind of like who in the
world is this kid and the response of
icarus is i don't know this kid i've
never met this kid
you know but at the end of the day he's
going to live i'm going to save him and
that's when you get this kind of
disembodied voice that says more eternal
blasphemy and a front against the
universe all that live
must die when i'm done there will be but
a single thing
that is eternal and that thing will be
death the person who teleported to the
eternal base of operations
killed xeros then teleported here to
titanos and killed all the remaining
eternals here
is thanos thanos is literally gonna do
everything he can to wipe out every
internal from existence
why he's gonna do that we don't know but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end let me know what you think
down in the comment section
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
you